[Musik]
freunde herzlich willkommen zu einer
neuen folge eintrag persönlicher kommt
diese show neben mir helfen papa platte
legende du wurdest du doch so oft
gewünscht dass ich glaube dass ich mal
eine echte fasste oder wer ist der
bessere oder heute gerne auf jeden fall
werde ich das heute bedienen und wir
fangen ganz entspannt an den fanshops in
einer kleinen variationen hat mir schon
14 mal und für dich einzige auflage
heute ist dieses format diesmal und
videos aber nur gekocht und ich sage
heute mittag das wird christoffers
verletzt glaubt so freuen wir machen wie
gesagt friend schoss dafür brauchen wir
natürlich los du willst dann kann es mit
talks machen aber bringt viel besser
dann natürlich noch sind milch eier und
ein bisschen zucker bleibt und für das
feeling halten wir es heute sind will
schön sommerlich ihr macht einfach
nutella und ihr habt richtig feeling das
heißt wir machen quasi ein franchise
sandwich deshalb noch erdbeeren so wir
fangen an nehmen ein wenig milch und
butter schuss dem das hier in unsere
form hinein
dazu geben wir 1 1 ein wenig zimt ein
wenig zucker noch dran und dann schaue
ich mir ein schneebesen und verkehr das
alles gut geschmeidig schon gegen hertha
worauf mittlere
und wir gehen ein bisschen butter 1 und
die hauptarbeit leistung wirklich unser
bier schweiß ist einfach unverzichtbar
wirklich sollte es muss sein
neben vier schöne scheiben aus der mitte
und da legen wir jetzt einfach das brio
schon mal kurz rein was man sich
komplett auf sorgen hatte ich hier rüber
und dann können wir später ganz
entspannt einfachen job
[Musik]
und dann gebe ich das auch schon mal mit
denen unsere fahne hinein und backes aus
okay leute
der entschluss hat schöne farbe bekommen
wir flicken jetzt mal leute hört ihr das
das hat obwohl es so soft ist in der
mitte diesem quatsch bekommen so ist die
hälfte der erdbeeren ca fein geschnitten
das wort auch reichen für 2000 das
anrichten
hier war er während zwischen 31 leiden
mit ich schön fühlen dann natürlich die
innenseite wird auch nochmal mit nutella
bestrichen dann können wir das ganze
auch schließen
da
[Musik]
kevin hat auch nie verschlossen frisch
gegessen
ich habe immer nur so normales gehabt
gemeint dass es viel geld ist schon sehr
krass artikel christoph foto machen so
wanderwoche ausgefeilte ganzen spaß eine
erste gar nicht zu viel sagen dann wird
auch belastende themen kleines mutti das
so
danke man auf jeden fall sehr korrekt so
kevin schnell sehr gespannt hat die
goldeck war übertrieben kasseler ich
muss wirklich sagen bis jetzt so viel
geiler als normales tod ja das ist auch
wie ich finde auch dass ich feiere das
sonst immer nicht so wenn du dir das
obst so dazu einfach ist ja deswegen war
es übertrieben
das ist so drin war ja ich muss jetzt
vereinzelt thema werden man eins bis
zehn werde ja das ist übertrieben leben
werde ich jetzt zu zählen gebe an denen
das war perfekt und ich würde
ok ich sag mal 9,5 ist schon das war
schon sehr sehr sehr sehr geil und leute
ich hab ich ja gesagt das wird
anspruchsvoll was wir jetzt machen wir
machen nämlich gulasch und kehrt erst
gesagt dass er selbst oft schon
wunderschön überhaupt kommt und es ist
so ein ding mit meiner familie das ist
immer wenn ich da bin bei meiner mom
oder so dann macht ihr das heißt du
musst jetzt quasi das besser als meine
mom ok weiter ich hätte mein bestes
geben ihr seht ihr eine möglichst breite
danke für die 9,5 und streng zu
zubereitungen mittag freund zu mittag
essen ist ist der tag davor und ich habe
hier vor mir den mein charakter stehen
und zwar rotkohl gemacht nämlich
rotkraut ist beginn des sommers aber
kevin hat sich das gewünscht deshalb
legen wir noch mal los alles was wir
brauchen sagt orangen sauber äpfel das
hier sind jetzt elfter zitronen von
gefangenen
die zunächst den rotkohl hier eine
halbieren
wir schneiden hier unten den strom ein
bisschen raus die wollen wir nämlich
nicht schmecken und damit auch schon
anfangen unseren kohl zu schneiden dabei
geht die maßgabe von meiner mama nämlich
extra auf dem memo gemacht wie sie ihren
berühmten rotkohl macht nicht zu dünn
und nicht zu grob danke mama also mit
anderen worten angeführt so das ist
perfekt einfach nur wichtig dass man das
ganze einen tag vorher wie gesagt
ansetzt weil das über nacht mariniert
und erst dann kann das wissen zu diesen
anderen geschmack aufbauen das geben wir
dann einfach hier und so eine große
schüssel in der wir das ganze dann
abonnieren mit allen anderen zutaten
aber wie gesagt erst mal weiter schlagen
dann benötigen wir den saft von vier
saft orangen ich habe 25 geholt aber die
sind ja immer so klein die sagte roger
wollen wir ein bisschen über unsere
arbeitsfläche kant auf dann kann man die
kerne direkt auffangen sagt läuft durch
den spaß manchmal zu viel saft auch auf
orangen sind drehen jetzt fügen wir noch
eine zitrone hinzu und dann fehlen nicht
nur super wenige zutaten zu unter
anderem zwei äpfel schälen wir als
erstes so äpfel sind geschält und wenn
der sprung raus ist schnappen uns
einfach die äpfel und reifen sind die
schützlinge so jetzt haben wir auch alle
fdp jetzt haben wir schon fast geschafft
wir haben noch ein paar zutaten der
eingang zum einen gewürze machen
eigentlich so ein gewürz beutelchen ich
habe jetzt aber einen kaffee tee und
improvisiert hilft mir hoffentlich dass
ich das ganze bisher weniger aussuchen
muss wir haben nämlich unter anderem
drei nelken die wieder hinein geben und
ihr wisst vielleicht nelken haben sie
irgendwie und außerdem keine
stange zählt nach wenig aus aber was auf
jeden fall einiges an geschmack sowie
das ist jetzt provisorisch wie gesagt
erst mal irgendwie hier rein zu bekommen
das dann morgen wieder raus rufen kann
so ich habe das jetzt einfach ein
bisschen provisorisch eingerollt und
hoffe dass es zusammenhält dann brauchen
wir noch zwei esslöffel wären wir
natürlich ordentlich zu 30 bekommen
fotos das einfach wohnt ein wenig rot
weiß roten wenn ihren guten schrott und
davon nehmen wir einen guten schluck
nicht mehr als 100 milliliter und jetzt
vor wir das ganze über nacht marinieren
lassen muss mir das noch mal gut durch
das geld meist hat sich mit der hand ein
paar machen auf das dom
wir benutzen das brett dass wir schon
die ganze zeit windows tage hoffen dass
es gut abschließt ich hab dann können
wir ein bisschen hin und her werfen so
und wenn das ganze jetzt gut vermengt
ist dann haben wir einfach wieder
unseren deckel drauf also ich könnte es
natürlich auch mit folie abdecken oder
sonstwie und dann wartet ihr einfach bis
zum nächsten tag so sieht der fernseher
einen tag später auf und es gibt
natürlich nicht nur rotkohl sondern auch
gulasch da wäre ich jetzt erstmal
loslegen so leute ich habe hier den kurs
weil ich habe ein richtig gutes match
hier in berlin und dachte ich jetzt eben
dass wir schöne große also sollen schön
groß aber halt auch nicht zu klein sein
die cola stücke aus den bereichen schon
mal vorbei da wird als allererstes
bin selbst sehr gespannt wie das heute
wird aber ich glaube in der kampf sagt
wir wollen die stücke wirklich relativ
groß haben und ich denke mal so sind wir
ganz gut verdient so der trick ist jetzt
ich will mal den gulasch in eine von
unseren schüssel wir wollen volumenmäßig
den gleichen anteil an gulasch und
zwiebeln also wir brauchen wirklich jede
menge zwiebel unten lässt man es
zusammen airport abziehen und dann werde
ich wahrscheinlich weinen müssen
zerfallen sowieso deshalb brauchen wir
da keine große angst zu haben
gleich haben anteil fleisch und zwiebel
und jetzt können wir den größten teil
den wir finden können nehmen und auf den
herrscher und in den topf geben wir
schon mal einen guten stich butter
schmalz wir geben jetzt mal hier in
unseren top international wohl sie
gesagt gut verteilt aber dann nichts
[Musik]
doch bremst ich habe ja auf einem brett
sich in drei teelöffel mutter dazu gebe
ich jetzt neben drei lorbeerblättern
zwei netten etwas kümmel satz 2 10
frischer knoblauch ein paar körner und
das mengen die jetzt quasi alles mit der
mutter zusammen uns herr hacken ist dann
die butter hilft das ist aber nichts vom
brett interface den trick hab ich hier
bei kalle kocht legende abgeschaut wie
kann man als zusammenzumischen freundes
gegen kurz vorher ich habe jetzt diesen
schon hinzugefügt das hat richtig jetzt
ist daran erkennt man dass der zeitpunkt
gekommen
alle flüssigkeit es raus und man kann
dann wie gesagt auf die ziele hinzufügen
lassen jetzt ein bisschen einfallen das
15 15 minuten und dann sehen wir uns
wieder freunde gucke ich das mal an
sieben nur lecker aus riecht auch
unglaublich lecker am topfboden hat sich
schon so eine kleine schicht gebildet
das ist super wir führen nämlich jetzt
vier esslöffel tomatenmark hinzu dann
jetzt ein guter schluck rotwein dazu
steht das tomatenmark besser aufzulösen
und deklassiert den boden das
gerade gezeigt da ist gut habe dann aber
mit rotwein können wir immer die
reststoffe ein bisschen raus lösen ich
sage immer weil wir wiederholen diesen
vorgang mit backen lassen und auslösen
wiederholen drei mal
sie hat nach dem dritten durchgang
dieses ist komplett gesäubert jetzt wird
es zeit für unser hauptzutat
paprikapulver zwei es geschafft zwei
esslöffel süß und das thema einfach dazu
und geben dann richtig action
dann haben wir natürlich noch hier
unseren teelöffel mit der butter die wir
vorbereitet haben
aber ab dem zeitpunkt wo das
paprikapulver drin ist aufpassen dass
man halt nicht mehr zu viel gezahlt und
nicht mehr
nicht mehr rasten obwohl das ja schon
sehr so fix wir natürlich keine
gulaschsuppe aber wir fühlen das ganze
auf mit sender von und zwar so viel dass
das gerade so stimmt ungefähr so will
und so haben wir es jetzt einfach kochen
für mindestens eineinhalb stunden muss
man gucken wann das falsche zahlen
müssen wie machen wir mit unserem roth
kunden auch gleich wieder eine zwiebel
die zwiebel wirken wir einfach kein
wasser das heißt das einfach nur ein
schluck so 50 milliliter oder so und da
führen wir jetzt die gesagt unseren
zucker 1
dann dass wir das ganze bei hoher hitze
stehen bis es sich braun und kanalisiert
kann man leute ich mache das hier
echtzeit mit einer sprachmemos von
meiner mom
das war heute ist karamellisiert jetzt
löschen wir ab es liegt jetzt ein
bisschen unangenehm aber ist wichtig
dann sehen wir dazu eine gute ecke
schmalz wenn es jetzt schweineschmalz
muss so unangenehm riechen hat meine mom
gesagt es habe keine sorgen weil es
nicht möglich grauen folgt ein staaten
ist die zwiebel an die dünnsten sie
einfach nur ein bisschen angst wo die
zwiebeln sind jetzt angedünstet das
heißt jetzt kommt der auftritt von
unserem rotkohl geben wir auch nach und
nach hier hinein mit der gesamten
marinade hoffen hier drin ist man
irgendwo dieses deutlich hier mit den
gewürzen und es hört sich nicht komplett
aufgelöst
dieser kaffeefilter soll aber auch mit
wind und jetzt decke drauf ankommen so
von rotkohl komplett eingekocht einfach
nur deckel drauf kochen lassen der coach
es auch sehr schön reduziert und hier
hinten leute nehmen es mir nicht übel
einfach mal fertig ist kann man
irgendwann auch noch mal selbst machen
aber das wird ja ich habe es sofort wir
mussten aber auch wirklich warten weil
es einfach kochen residierte boden
richtung sogar wert alles finde ich cool
abgekocht also ich war bei sturm ich war
beiden und ich hab schon jahrelang von
meiner mutter bekommen ist ein deutscher
satz kann habe ich weiß auch nicht mehr
nur noch in jedem fall harte konkurrenz
ich hoffe ich hoffe es schmeckt aber ich
bin gespannt als er vor allem auf das
rotkohl ja richtig geil
okay das wäre ich wieder da
wir haben nochmal eine fette und fährt
einen nachschlag bei der landvolk aber
ich glaube schon seid ihr geschmeckt
er war übertrieben ist richtig
weihnachtsmann frisst sich mit der
familie folgte ja also was soll ich
sagen
wahrscheinlich der beste gut dastehen
ich bis jetzt gegessen habe
also der ist auf jeden fall mit 10 100
prozentig rotkohl finde ich auch sehr
geil geschmack aber ich glaube es hätte
noch ein stückchen länger gekommen
können das noch so manche gerne ist
insgesamt trotzdem ist übertrieben ist
wirklich wichtig wer dachte dass das
dein lieblingsessen jahr das ja hat das
war hart ist das also es ist ein sehr
großes lob ich war so bei der ersten
gabe von dem gut aus war ich so hätte
das natürlich sagen leute wer ist sehr
geschmeidig sehr sehr bitter crazy dann
muss probiert irgendwie daran
anzuknüpfen aber nicht bevor ich das
erstmal irgendwie drei stellen auf der
couch gelegen
wir sind jetzt noch nicht den spaß
manchmal spielt meine kamera nicht so
richtig mit oder können sie auch einfach
nicht richtig bedienen
deshalb erzählt hier einfach nach und
nach was ich gemacht habe bis zu dem
zeitpunkt an dem die kamera weg ist ich
habe angefangen dem ich eine große
zwiebel fein gewürfelt habe und eine
fahne auf mittlerer hitze auf dem herd
platziert da habe ich mit vier spitz
paprikas geschnappt von stil und kernen
befreit und anschließend auch gewürfelt
während paprika und zwiebeln weich
gedünstet wurden habe ich auch zwei
knoblauchzehen fein gehackt pressen geht
natürlich auch anschließend habe ich den
knoblauch dazugeben und kurz angedünstet
auf jeden fall nicht braun werden lassen
danach kam auch schon zwei dosen
geschälte tomaten dazu die habe ich ein
wenig mit dem kochlöffel zerkleinert und
das ganze anschließend zehn minuten
köcheln lassen bis ein großteil der
feuchtigkeit verkauft war und dass die
kamera auch schon wieder leute also gar
nicht so schlimm aber ich sag mal so
viel
ich glaube in zukunft passiert das nicht
mehr sorgen so ihr seht das zieht jetzt
so ganz langsam werden jetzt hat man
genug spielraum um da auch die eier
hinein zu schlagen das ist auch
gleichzeitig zum ersten mal hier in der
mitte an und dann kann man hier immer
schön auf den rand noch ein wenig an dem
tomaten und paprika drauf machen und
dann gehen wir jetzt einfach unseren
deckel drauf so freuen ihr seht es
natürlich dass wir den deckel drauf
hatten ist das hier schon gut an
gestoppt und man muss es dann auch ein
bisschen früher als man es raus haben
will ziehen bei möglicherweise das
behält ja die hitze das stock noch ein
bisschen weiter
also nehme ich jetzt mal runter und
damit das schön an schmelz gebe ich
jetzt hier oben auch schon in väter ich
glaube das ganze mit ein bisschen
frischer tat
da können wir auch schon zu nennen
nehmen wir gerne auf ich habe die nummer
die sie mit frisch angetastet koreanerin
und martin sieht doch hier für butter
ist ja einfach so ein miethaus picken
ist das störe das komplette gebäude
richtig ist weil es einfach drauf kommt
ganz kurz probiert dass man sich direkt
mit einem stick mit miami nachts wie
gesagt noch nie gegessen das gericht
auch hinter sehr gut passt gut zusammen
werde ich wird so fett werden etwas
machen über lang gratis
ja wo also ist auch super lecker und ich
muss sagen so im vergleich und ich
konnte ja jedes zu vergleichen mit dem
was ich schon gegessen habt ja im
vergleich zu dem was ich schon gegessen
habe abbas lightly weniger aber trotzdem
sehr geil ich hätte denke ich einen
neuen leitfaden über dich lieben
gehalten mit diesem lied das war
übertrieben heftig sicher das hast du
bist selber gemacht na ja trotzdem sehr
sehr geil kam trust
also nur noch zehn tage dann geht
wirklich ein koch intensiver und sehr
sehr lecker tag zu ändern also ich habe
heute auch sehr gerne ist hat mich alles
super geschmeckt hat es auch sehr gerne
gemacht wir sehen uns nächsten
donnerstag wieder oder nächsten sonntag
zur nächsten folge persönlicher koch
machs gut bis dahin und schauen und aus
dem ruder und ja wichtig und schon
vorbei
[Musik]